back to the gas prices i had a
conversation with my mom yesterday and
my mom is zero percent knowledge about
what's going on so i posed the question
i go mom how much does it cost to fill
your tank
she says it costs 40 bucks i said well
you do understand now that gas prices
are rising
she goes yeah i know it cost me 50 this
week to fill my tank
so how often do you fill your tank once
a week so i said it's gonna cost you ten
dollars more you know in general to fill
your tank she goes
okay
like to combat tyranny
and to stand up
against
autocratic
thinking like putin if it costs my mom
who's a nurse
ten dollars more a week
so be it
you know gas prices aren't the end all
be all yes there are bigger things like
the trucker that you talked about and
businesses or people who drive for a
living you know maybe you eat out a
little bit less but you're gonna have to
do something different but for my mom to
spend ten dollars more a week
so be it so so so i will i will uh take
a different position with that
and uh and i'll tell you this so
right now the the crisis is so bad on
the left
that they have to figure out a way
to either take a few different measures
to not make the gas price a massive
issue so they're they're they're facing
a few different problems why are we
having so many
uh uh problems world we didn't have a
war during trump why are we having so
many problems
under this administration why is that
first we have the afghanistan now we
have this first we have inflation gas
prices go up now we have this
why is this happening we just had a
worldwide pandemic so i mean a lot of
this is systemic because of that
right but again so even with the
pandemic throw that in there as well
why why so the
the left has to position everything to
be normal it's okay it's gas prices just
going up it's okay you know it's
inflation it's going to be okay it's
going to go away no it's not really
inflation it's because of this oh it's
really going on because they have to
deflect deflect deflect because midterms
there's an element of it that's politics
but
the part of it that with your mom's
story i'm glad it doesn't affect you the
ten bucks i'm fully glad it doesn't
affect her it affects a lot of people
believe me my mom is of the elk that it
would affect the comments i i get that
she doesn't by no way means doing it but
your mom is also not in the working
environment where she has kids to take
care of where she has expenses to cover
where she has to drop off the kids drive
them to soccer and all that other stuff
she's a retired woman that is not
necessarily have 50 different things to
do when you were 12 years old and when
you were eight years old it's a
different life for somebody that's going
through that trying to survive on a time
like that but the price increase is
going to be felt and it's not just going
to be gas gas is only one thing we're
talking about just watch all the other
prices and fyi
if you think the gas prices are at the
peak right now
people
are lying to themselves or they're naive
wait till this thing gets to ten dollars
and everybody has to have the real
conversations about
listen i was kind of okay at four
dollars
but
i'm not okay with ten dollars don't you
think at that point a biden
administration will start opening up the
floodgates of oil what's the difference
between starting now and then what is
the difference between that wouldn't be
shocked if they started now well well
yesterday they announced that they're
going to ban russian oil okay so where
do we think we're going to get oil from
okay so we're going to have to aim and
that's why we're no no negotiations are
happening right yeah there you go so if
you rush
bandwidth russia that's a very good
strategy
for pr that's great to say we're not
doing it with pr great like mcdonald's
we're shutting down 700 stores in russia
starbucks okay this is good you have to
do that because your customers are going
to be like what are you like you know
these
restaurants liquor stores are coming out
and pouring all their vodka you know and
then somebody came back and said the
following they said oh really you're
pouring all this stuff out of vodka why
don't you go throw all this stuff out
that you have in your store that says
made in china if you're really not
committed why don't you go out and drop
all the meat in china stuff nobody's
saying that oh you're only saying
because this is cool to do that right
you wouldn't even think about doing it
if you were supposed to drop all the
stuff and made in china because you do
so much money so there's so much
hypocrisy in this thing right now that
you just you just have to kind of really
see
uh what's going on but but this this gas
crisis if it hits 10
and biden's still trying to negotiate
his camp with maduro's camp venezuela or
saudi arabia or they're already in talks
or iran or all these other guys we look
so weak you're negotiating with the
enemy hey
can you please sell us some gas at a
discount please things are pretty bad in
america why don't you go get it yourself
and then they asked maybe we will though
right the maybe is if they do we will
salute them on the podcast and say
awesome decision for you doing well if
you were if you were tony blinken or in
a national security advisor working for
the biden administration you just
hypothetically
what what would you recommend he does
differently or what do you what advice
would you
what council would you have access to
all the intel if i had access to all of
you based on you know if i had access to
all the intel and i got people around me
from both sides giving me feedback on
why to or why not to
then i would ask and say what so we got
a hundred years of reserve yes okay how
long do you think this crisis gonna last
say 90 days okay 100 years 90 days means
we got 400 more years of reserves why
don't we go ahead and get 90 days worth
of supply right now lower the gas prices
by 25 35 40 percent and then 90 days
later we can go back and see what we can
strike up a deal with somebody else okay
maybe you can put a timeline on it that
we're gonna
fix it for now but here's the other part
that i'll flip it on you is there's got
to be a long-term solution okay there
has to be a long-term solution these are
all nice band-aids you're putting on
there okay
reactionary oh reactionary oh
reactionary but what's the long-term
solution
the long-term solution is the one i'm
i'm really interested in because it's
both ways to go green
you know the eevee part nuclear you know
whether it's the nuclear the fossil the
other
solar there's got to be
there's like for example california
yesterday newsome posted something on
twitter i'm like oh my god here he goes
again
he posted something on the uh on twitter
yesterday bragging about how great
california is doing i don't know if you
saw that or not he said california
raised the minimum wage we increased
paid sick leave provided more paid
family leave expanded child care you
know
and this year will be the first state to
provide health care for all regardless
of immigration status that's the
california way did you see what i said
to him
and then i i said i wouldn't brag about
it your policies caused california's
population to drop by 182 000 last year
making it the first yearly law since its
founding in 1850s
bad policies have consequences right bad
policies have consequences
the the political system that we have
today the voting system adam it's so uh
reactionary that everybody is more
concerned about being re-elected that
you're not making good long-term policy
but you don't i mean you lived in
california so you have obviously strong
opinions on this i don't feel bad for
californians
why they chose this
no no question about it they they they
had the opportunity
to
cut off newsome and they overwhelmingly
by two thirds i guarantee voted to keep
them i guarantee you in the comments
section right now 40 are saying you
don't that they don't speak on my behalf
well and let's not forget what
california did they perma
permanently enrolled or instilled
mail-in balloting they're allowing
illegal immigrants to vote they have a
huge population of sanctuary cities it's
like the the the yes that's still
knocking out that's still not going to
change the vote whatsoever well i mean
there's there could be some
discrimination
in the country arguably so
sanctuary cities they're cute and all
but they're not swaying
millions and millions and millions of
voters well again there could be some
discrepancies in the actual voting
process if it was a you know
55 45 vote all right maybe
70 30 not so much
go back to the fact that we are
we're dealing with a population that
isn't educated well enough to understand
you know
if i vote for this
somebody has to pay for that
and
how does it all balance out
and you know the stuff that newsom just
bragged about somebody has to pay for
that so your taxes will go up again
right
and uh you know i was recently in in la
what a dump
what a dump lax is uh what's that to say
that that was a beautiful city man
uh
there's homeless camps all over the
place and the city is drab there's just
nothing that looks inviting anymore yet
there's still
people living there
but but my friends who have some means
they all live some place outside of
the city
it's it's a shame and i i've been given
to understand that san francisco looks
pretty much the same these days that san
francisco is worse than the last the
prettiest city that ever was in the
united states san francisco yeah
now it's a hot mess so so why don't they
connect the dots
did that just happen
just sporadically and there's nobody to
be held accountable before
where do you live i live in outside of
atlanta atlanta yeah okay pretty good
atlanta yeah night traffic though look
at that look at that real quick look at
that real quick
what's that that's l.a oh yeah
oh god that is la that's insane to think
that's la see i don't remember it
looking like that i lived there 20 plus
years
i remember looking like that that's
what's what they're doing is they're
raiding the trains when the trains come
in from amazon fedex the packages they
gangs of people go up rip the trains
open steal all the packages steal all
the goods and take off
yeah i mean that definitely inspires
people to say i'm going to wake up and
move to california tomorrow
i'm definitely on my way to go to
california tomorrow i just wonder how
long this is going to go because nothing
lasts forever you have to know that
winning doesn't last forever you're
eventually going to lose you know
the bulls you know dynasty six years
bomb lakers kobe shack bomb you got you
know whatever
so nothing
it doesn't last forever i just wonder
what's going to happen to california
where some of them are going to wake up
and say you know what i'm done with this
so if you enjoyed this little segment
from the podcast click over here to
watch the entire podcast and if you're
not subscribed to the channel please do
so take care everybody
[Music]
you